- Do you know, I wish I would've used
an eye drop or two before this started.
- Is that right?
- Yeah.
- Why, do you wanna blink?
(daunting music)
Yo, wassup?
This your homie, Ice Cube.
I'm here at Buzzfeed.
We out here for the big three.
Gonna have a staring contest.
First person that blinks, loses.
They don't know they
having the contest with me.
You know trash talkin' is allowed.
They ain't gon' be able to stay (bleep).
(adventurous music)
- I've been wearing this
blindfold for like five minutes.
- Alright, sorry.
- [Producer] Alright, so you
can take your blindfold off,
but keep your eyes closed.
- Okay.
- [Producer] Alright, ready?
Now you're going to try to
win a staring contest, ready?
- Yep.
- [Producer] Three. Two. One. Go.
(suspenseful music)
(laughs)
- It's nice to meet you
dude, how's it going?
- [Producer] Good game.
- Alright. Good. He held it.
- I tried.
- I saw his pupil going up and down.
- Do I do it now? (laughs)
- [Producer] No not yet, hands down! Go.
- Look? - [Producer] Yep.
- Oh, damn! (laughs)
- I think she lost that match (laughs)
- Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Damn!
Oh (bleep)! Oh my god
that's so (bleep) cool.
- How do you lose? By
blinking or laughing?
- [Producer] Blinking.
- Go.
(suspenseful music)
- Oh, I just blinked (laughs)
and now I'm crying a little bit.
(laughing)
- Wassup man.
- Hi.
- How you doin'?
- (laughs) I can't--
- [Producer] You can even
pull it straight down.
- Okay I got it. - [Producer] Go.
(suspenseful music)
- I blinked (laughs)
- [Producer] Oh!
(laughing loudly)
- [Producer] He's on fire.
- East Coast gonna-- (laughs)
- Okay, now you're-- good for you.
- Oh, you throwing the--
- I was right! I was right!
- No gang-banging.
- [Producer] Take your blindfold off.
- Okay. - [Producer] Go.
(suspenseful music)
- Don't blink.
- The light-- (clears throat)
It's kinda-- Oh, I blinked. I blinked.
(laughter)
That was crazy, it was really
nice meeting you! (laughs)
- Oh my god. Okay. - [Producer] Go.
(suspenseful music)
(laughs)
- Don't blink.
- Oh! (laughs)
- Nice to meet you, I'm Nicki.
- Nice to meet you, Nicki.
- [Producer] It's been a
good game, shake hands.
- Wait. Oh it's a little chair.
- [Producer] It's a little chair. Go.
(suspenseful music)
(laughs)
- Hey.
- Wassup?
- How you doin'? - How you doin'?
- Ah, you know I wish I
would've used an eye-drop or two
before this started. (laughs)
- Is that right? - Yeah
- Why, you wanna blink?
I think I blinked two or three times.
- Okay (laughs) Now I just shut
my eyes totally, oh my god.
Hi! - How you doin'. - Nice to meet you!
- [Producer] Three. Two. One. Go.
(suspenseful music)
- (Beep) you're good.
I'm so-- (beep) it, I lost.
(laughter) Oh my god. - Wassup?
- That was really good
man, thank you so much.
- Did anyone win?
- Nobody. I mean one, but I was talking,
and I started blinking. - Oh (beep).
- [Producer] Three. Two. One. Go.
- Wassup man?
Don't blink.
- Oh (beep). Did I lose? (laughs) Oh.
- You lost.
- That's not fair, I didn't know
whether I could blink or not!
- [Producer] It's a staring contest!
- I told you don't blink.
- I mean--- thanks dude.
- Alright, be cool, you lost
(laughter)
- [Producer] Lauren, you are
across from our celebrity here.
Go.
- Don't blink.
(laughs)
- I definitely can't-- hey. - Hey.
- Did I blink? - I think so.
(laugher)
- I'm like, I'm not blinking (laughter)
- [Producer] It was a call out. (laughter)
- Nice to meet you. -
Nice to meet you too.
- [Producer] Thank you for competing.
- Yeah (laughs) - Thanks
for having me. (laughs)
- Hey thanks for watching.
Be sure to watch the
big three championship,
tonight on FOX 8 o'clock Eastern.
(rhythmic drumming music)